I don't eat as much as I used to.
I just feel so much better when I just skipped the middle meal and like whose
idea was it?
Three meals a day anyway and you don't need that.
Right.
And I've found that I can live very comfortably.
I'm not into like torturing myself.
Like I'm going to starve and nail myself to this chair.
But you know,
if I'm too just too distracted to work as I'm hungry I need to address that.
But what I found is if I just kind of don't eat a lot after a couple of days,
I'm like a jet in the high air where you're burning no fuel cause you're just in
the thin air where I walked pie food going like Nah,
I've had like two meals in the last two and a half meals like in the last three
days and I feel fine actually.
I feel like really bouncy.
Like I don't need the,
the postworkout seven minute power nap.
I,
I'm feeling really good.
Do you do intermittent fasting at all?
Um,
yes.
On the,
the woman I work with,
you know Heidi,
she does that sometimes and I'll just follow her lead.
So she'll go,
hey,
I'm doing this.
I'll,
I'll try that because I just don't know this stuff.
And she knows a lot more about it than I do.
So I just do what she does.
And so a few years ago he got into like one meal a day.
I was just trying it out.
No one told me to.
I was in India of all places and I was out all day taking photos and sweating
and I would eat dinner and that would be it.
And I would like sleep through breakfast and go back out and with my camera.
So dinner became my meal and the first three days of that was a little tough.
And then it was like I never wanted,
I kind of felt bad when I went back to the western boy.
I'm eating a lot of food.
Your body adapts.
Yeah,
well we can adapt.
You can live on pizza for the rest of your life,
very happily,
all,
you know,
whatever.
But your body really does adapt to that.
Intermittent that time will not,
I'm saying it'll adapt to anything.
It'll adapt to too much food and Moodle depth to like a fraction of what you
used to eat right here.
But just,
here's what I have found.
When I start limiting the food,
I'm more alert.
My sleep is more restorative and I bounce out of bed,
like just flying out of bed.
I don't have that afternoon drowsiness.
I just stay with it and I just feel way more buoyant and present,
uh,
type faster,
just concentrate more.
And I,
when I'm on tour,
it's usually I do one point something meals a day.
Like I'm about to leave on tour.
It'll be,
it's an evening meal post,
show
myself into an eight hour feeding window and 16 hour fasting window every day
hall.
And I've been pretty consistent with that over the last like four or five
months.
And as a,
it has a big impact man.
When you,
when I eat dinner,
you know,
say if I'm done at eight o'clock,
I just time it out.
16 hours later is when my first meal comes.
I can have a coffee in between now and then,
but nothing with any real significant calories.
I'm just having some liquid or something like that.
And that's it.
And then it just,
by doing that man,
I just like,
I wake up in the morning,
I'm not craving breakfast.
I'm not,
I'm not even hungry.
My body's is totally adapted to it.
Yeah.
It just gives your body a chance to digest.
I think we're always in a state of feeding and your body just never has really a
chance to digest.
Lot of juggling.
You know,
the body's like,
as it's processing,
it's incoming.
Like really another order never gets to realize digestion.
Like,
yeah,
we're done.
It's always like,
you're like a cow.
They're always processing nutrition.
Uh,
and I,
I wonder if that's a western model because in other parts of the world,
people live very differently than we do.
It just,
it is what it is.
And a meal.
This,
it's almost just a thing that happens now and then it's not like it's dinner
time and we're going to talk about report cards and gathering.
It's like the whole family works all over the city and they're going to eat,
I think get some point where every even sleep you go to like parts like Vietnam
and people just like sleeping behind the counter of the store they work at
because they'd been there for a day and a half because mom can't come in.
So there were running the store and they sleep as this thing that you get now
and then and I think food is like that and a lot of parts of the world,
like a meal,
Eh,
uh,
the next time I eat will be the next time I eat.
When you go to these places,
and I know you traveled pretty much all over the world,
do you go out of your way to try to sample in as wide a variety as the local
cuisines?
You can,
no,
no.
Depends on where I go.
And I'm not that dye who just brings it all from home and I never leave home
when I'm abroad,
but I can't afford to eat a bad meal and be a bedridden,
bedridden for the next day when I should be out hitting the streets,
looking at stuff.
And so I've had,
you know,
as you do,
you run into the bad meal where you're like hugging a tree,
watching the arc of vomit.
Like wow,
Linda Blair.
And I've done that from here to a Mayan Mar and Russia,
wherever.
I've had some bad meals.
And so when the food looks dodgy,
like in the interior of Africa where you pointed the meat object and go,
what is that?
And the guy will say,
I think it's goat
Clif bar just because I just can't.
And so what I've learned to do,
and it's hard on your back cause it's a lot of weight.
I take say I'm going to be out in Africa for two weeks.
I bring about two meals worth of chow with me.
That's a lot of nuts.
A lot of clif bars,
a lot of like peanut butter and you know things that just don't go bad and heat
where I can just look at the food and gum.
No,
no,
not tonight.
It's going to be a handful of almonds and this and water also in parts of the
world were waters dodgy.
You find a store,
you buy the box of water,
rip it open to
make sure it hasn't been tampered with by the whole box.
Put it in your backpack and lug 40 pounds of water for the next five days.
It sucks.
But you,
you can't be somewhere and be like,
Ay,
I'm thirsty.
And I don't know about that water cause that could go sign the,
you know they have these portable backpack filters and Steri pens and things
that a lot of backpack hikers they use there.
They're very small now.
They're very small and lightweight and you can get some,
like if you're saying in a place and you think it has dodgy water,
you can get a gravity filter.
Oh you put water.
Like you could literally get rain water from outside in a puddle.
And I don't know.
A lot of people do that and they take it and they put it in this large gravity
filter and a drip down,
almost like it looks like someone's peeing at the bottom of this huge bag of 60
liter bag of water,
but it filters at all and it allows you to drink basically puddle water.